rarely to the Giants of Dark Souls have
happy fates in the age of the gods they
had at best
perhaps because one of their own was a
powerful night of Gwyn yet even then he
suffered at the hands of former humans
who packed his helm with tree resin and
fooled him into thinking he was blind
the other Giants of this age were put to
use as basic laborers their wits made
them unfit for much else except in rare
occasions in drangleic a distant race of
giants invade the kingdom of the humans
to take back that which was stolen from
them
it ends in bloodshed not to mention the
Giants taken for experimentation their
very souls becoming displaced from their
bodies and finally lothric where their
abuse its new heights imprisoned forced
to wallow in the mark of the cathedral
slaughtered or feigning death only one
rose above the rest and even ruled over
humans your yawn is the descendant of an
ancient Conqueror a conqueror who once
subdued the people of the profaned
capital and in time
yawm was asked by these very same people
to lead them he would come to accept
this role and he served as both their
weighty blade and their stone hard
shield and he would think that this
transfer of power would earn him the
people's respect and gratitude but it
didn't
instead those who spoke of yawn as Lord
were quite insincere
perhaps this is because of yawns
heritage we don't know who the Conqueror
before yawn once and he might not even
be featured in game our two biggest
clues however are your size and the fact
that the people of the capital suddenly
found themselves without a ruler or
protector and needed to ask for one and
in my opinion wall near the enormous
conqueror of Karthus who suddenly fell
to the abyss fits this criteria or at
least is a good example of it wall near
once brought the rightful Lords of the
world to their knees and ground their
crowns to dust
however he went on to fall to the abyss
presumably living many kingdoms without
a ruler and while there wasn't exactly
known for sharing his power with others
so at the very least it was probably an
absence of rule like this that led the
people of the capital to ask for a
powerful protector instead of simply
being conquered all over again so it
fits that they would ask yawn yet it
also fits that they would feel some
shame for having to ask him their fate
would be in the hands of the conquerors
descendant and not just that but in the
hands of a giant no less simpletons and
dollard's with very few notable
exceptions
soyou're fought hard to prove himself as
Lord risking everything for his people
against the kingdom's enemies he fought
unflinchingly great machete in one hand
and great shield in the other yet still
his people's shame and Prejudice must
have manifested as bitterness distrust
for in another brave gesture yome gave
his people the means to defeat him a
storm ruler an ancient sword also known
as giant slayer capable of bringing
giants to their knees from the strength
of storm held within it
you're married two of these and now only
one remained in his possession at some
point during the wars you're lost the
one he wished to protect it's not clear
who this is whether they were a friend
or a partner nor how they died but this
loss became the legacy of his later
years it was an event so significant he
threw away his great shield for he was
no longer interested in
self-preservation nor the protection of
others in the place of his shield you're
mad at a left-handed knotch to his
machete enabling the Smashing technique
of a berserker with nothing left to lose
in time his enemies were crushed and the
only threat to the capital was from
within the group of women relatives of
some Oracle from a bygone age suddenly
triggered a curse subsisting deep within
them they all distorted into this same
monstrosity an enormous hand with
calcified protrusions and a hole boiling
deep within the palm despite all of this
they went on living without any cares
and from that day forward the profaned
flame was born within the capital the
profaned flame it came to define the
capital and it was defined by three
rules one it is said to be
inextinguishable two it is able to
swallow the hearts of those it touches
inspiring cruelty and torture and three
the darkness of the abyss can be seen
within it
with nothing left to lose and a
monumental soul to burn your miss I de
delink the fire with this act he would
put the profaned flame to rest enable a
new age of fire and prove his detractors
wrong show them all they were wrong
about him so just as he gave one storm
ruler to those who doubted him he gave
the other to one that he trusted along
with a promise that secret this bumbling
kind-hearted Knight of Catarina would
slay his old friend if he ever faltered
in his duty and so the fire was linked
and young failed in all the ways that
they said he would in this place we get
an unprecedented look into the linking
of the fire when it happened
items say a rush of flame fell from the
sky and incinerated not only your m--
but all the residents of the capital so
the question we're left asking is was
this normal or was your mole somehow not
enough but were giants not supposed to
link the fire for all his hard work
protecting these people they all went up
in flames and I assume his detractors
would have felt validated in doubting
your if they weren't all burnt to a
crisp ages past bolstered in part by
your sacrifice but the fire inevitably
fades and your is brought back from the
dead to link the fire once more there
must be something about a second chance
at life that causes a lord to fear death
for like the other two Lords who rose
alongside him you own flees his duty and
settles in the ruined capital he once
called home he takes his old throne
which is now surrounded by the melted
corpses of those who once doubted him
and he waits truly alone this time even
more so than he was in life
moment has almost come I just need a bit
more time secret with a little help from
you of course
finds the courage to meet his old friend
[Music]
your old friend I Seifert of the Knights
of Catarina have come to uphold my voice
let the Sun Shine upon this Lord of
sinner
[Music]
it seems I'm in your debt
once again my sex I could have not kept
my promise without your now for a final
toast to your vana and my old friend
your long may the Sun Shine well I'm
going to have myself a little nap the
only thing to do really after a nice
toast you are a true friend best of luck
with your duty after your final toast
and as you leave the arena see good soul
floats towards you did he die from
wounds that he sustained during the
fight it's impossible you'd think
considering that seed brow has healing
properties no his quest is complete his
oath is fulfilled
so Sieg wood ends his life for all that
remained was that final toast and to
wish you luck with your duty in the end
all that came from the profaned capital
where the cinders of award fits only to
surrender its fire for your ambition so
knowing all of this and all of what
happened what do you make of it oh and
did I forget to mention the profaned
flame burns on exempt from the tragedy
and waiting for more hearts to corrupt
and somewhere a young sorcerer escapes a
painting
[Music]
you